and tonight we start in baltimore which
was the scene of cnn's newest hit show
the mystery of the missing podium
despite the efforts of the brightest
minds in television the likes of don
lemon and jeffrey tubin the podium was
never found what is joe biden resting
his hands on what is he doing
is he imitating the great cornholio
is he holding tight to coherence
we'll never know
because they did not find the missing
podium instead cnn aired a disastrous
town hall
with president biden last night
but but here's the point
we're in a situation now where if you
are in a circumstance
that you're not able to
provide
let me cut to the chase i'm taking too
long
that was our president
doing his best grandpa simpson
impression they're getting lost in his
own story but if you listened to the
left-wing media they'd make you think
biden's performance was on par with a
victorious general patton parading
through the streets of paris
yeah i think he showed
he was he was commanding and yet
comfortable this is not a presidency in
crisis this didn't look like a guy whose
poll numbers have dropped he showed wit
he was able to laugh at himself i just
thought this was a guy truly in command
of the presidency
this this this is the worst magic trick
in history i can see the card up your
sleeve paul begala your lies they're
obvious
i'm not sure what town hall he was
watching but it clearly wasn't the one
that aired on his network and to be fair
to begala he probably didn't watch no
one did mr 80 million votes didn't break
the top 20 in cable news
would you describe this answer as quote
commanding
40 of all products coming into the
united states of america on the west
coast go through
uh los angeles and uh and uh um uh um
what am i doing here is it long beach
long beach thank you
what are you doing here let me help you
out you're supposed to be
running the country and fixing a supply
chain crisis or any crisis for that
matter pick a card any card pick a
crisis any crisis as you wander around
the stage
do you have plans to visit the southern
border i've been there before and i
haven't i mean i know it well i guess i
should go down but the
but the whole point of it is i haven't
had a whole hell of a lot of time to get
down
i'm gonna let me see
let's see if we can diagram that
sentence okay i
i've been there before and i haven't
but i know it well it
is that confusion it's certainly a
contradiction
is that a lie and then a correction
slowly backing away from the obvious lie
joe biden has never toured the southern
border according to fox news now as
president vice president senator or even
a concerned citizen he has never visited
the southern border well jinsaki told us
today that he drove around in the
vicinity perhaps through the border once
but come on really is that your answer
he drove by it once
and while joe spends his weekends in
delaware there have been nearly two
million apprehensions along the southern
border in 2021 alone that's the highest
number ever recorded
and look we still have two more months
to go
maybe you're right joe i guess you
should get on down there and see what's
going on but as biden forget the name of
one america's biggest ports and lies
about going to the southern border we're
led to ask
who's in charge of this white house who
is running the country
do you presume to criticize the great
ours
you are grateful creatures think
yourselves lucky that i'm giving you
audience tomorrow instead of 20 years
from now
oh
the great ours has spoken
oh
pay no attention to that man behind the
curtain
this is
this is what democrats want for you to
ignore whoever is pulling the strings of
joe biden so who is it who is it that's
behind the curtain
hey maybe it's dr jill jo hasn't been to
the border but she has
now my wife jill has been down she's
been on both sides of the river she's
seen the circumstances there she's
looked into those places
so jill biden has more border experience
than our president that's a really
promising sign
but if jill biden's not the wizard of oz
then who is maybe maybe it's joe's old
boss barack obama who's the great and
powerful eyes
the tax rate the corporate tax rate was
35 point some percent 37 percent
brock and i thought it should come down
the paris accord which when i was with
the obama administration we helped
negotiate in the obama bid
administration
well
joe spends a lot of time
awful lot of time talking about the
former president while not acting very
presidential himself
maybe he's not the great and powerful
laws maybe it's the cdc maybe dr anthony
fauci is the man behind the curtain
more on that in just a moment coming up
on fox news prime time
but the scariest answer to this question
may be that no one is pulling the
strings on biden because every day this
white house looks more and more like a
rudderless ship that is spinning around
in circles almost like wandering around
a cnn
town hall hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else